it's the start of trading at this tiny
shoe store just to stone throw from the
plasma dome in Paris
inside a luxury pair of Cortez men shoes
are being made or by hand the creme de
la creme according to the French
Ministry of Culture pure quartet started
by making bespoke shoes for high-profile
customers for me today
they include actors Clive Owen and Cate
Blanchett tennis player Rafael Nadal and
rich French clients such as the runt
River CEO and his extravagant Footwear
fake laces here and an elastic and after
of caught up or come on the last it
takes up to three people and fifty hours
to create a specially designed pair of
cocktails but the brand has also
launched ready to wear shoes in a large
range of colors today the man accept
more and more this feminine par price is
thought at $1500 and which up to more
than ten thousand dollars for the best
crocodile leather the CEO of Cote who
rescued the company from the brink
in 2010 wouldn't tell us how many the
sell he wants the brand to remain
exclusive it's a small baby that we're
trying to develop in a healthy way so
not force-feed him like a faux fur guy
beside Paris Cote has tours in London
Tokyo Hong Kong Dubai and corners in
Saks Fifth Avenue in the US and it's
planning most selective expansion we are
not fashion dictators but nice Court
issues can really help a hugly shoes
you